Welcome to Academy
Dialogues It Starts With Us.
My name is Shawn Finnie.
We are continuing our
series of conversations
about race, ethnicity,
history, opportunity,
in the art of filmmaking
hosted by the Academy.
Today's topic is
owning our stories.
We're incredibly honored to
have Bird Runningwater, director
of Sundance Institute's
Indigenous Programs
moderating our
conversation today.
Joining Bird, are screenwriter
Misan Sagay, writer, director,
actor Elle-Máijá
Tailfeathers, writer,
producer Ligiah Villalobos
and writer, director,
producer Lulu Wang.
Here's a little background
on each of our speakers.
As director of the Sundance
Institute's Indigenous
Programs, Bird oversees the
Sundance Native filmmakers lab,
the Native producers fellowship
and the festival's Native form.
A native of the Cheyenne
Mescalero Apache tribes,
Bird has been with Sundance
for the last 10 years,
supporting the buildup of
a global Indigenous film
community.
He is skilled in leading panel
discussions and workshops
around the world and has
worked with major institutions,
including the Ford and
Rockefeller foundations.
He holds degrees in
journalism, public affairs,
and Native studies.
In fact, he was
the first graduate
of the Native American
Studies Program
at the University of Oklahoma.
Misan is a native of Nigeria,
who was raised in England
and amazingly had a career
as an emergency room doctor
before becoming a screenwriter.
She wrote the script for
the 2013 movie Belle,
about the daughter of an
enslaved African woman
and a British admiral set
in 1700s British society.
Her credits also include the
teleplay for the Oprah Winfrey
produced movie, Their
Eyes Were Watching
God, and co-writer for
the six-part series,
Gorilla, starring Idris Elba
and produced by John Ridley,
the writer of 12 Years a Slave.
Elle-Maija Tailfeathers
is a rising filmmaker
who is bringing compelling
authentic stories
about Indigenous
people to the screen.
She comes from Sámi,
the Indigenous territory
of the Sámi people
in northern Europe.
She is also part of the
Kainai First Nation Blackfoot
Confederacy.
Her films include the multi
award, a documentary short,
Rebel, which is autobiographical
and the feature, The Body
Remembers When The World Broke
Open, which she co-wrote,
co-directed, and acted in.
It premiered in 2019 at
the Toronto Film Festival,
receiving three awards,
including best picture
and at the Berlin Film Festival.
Ligiah Villalobos
has had a long career
as both studio executive
and a filmmaker.
Her many film credits
include writing and executive
producing the independent
feature, La Misma Luna,
also known as Under
the Same Moon.
Writing the film
Firelight, produced
by Alicia Keys and Mary
Martin and consulting on Pixar
animated features
including Coco.
Firelight was nominated
for NAACP Image Award
and received a 2013
humanities prize.
Lulu Wang first gained
international attention
for writing and directing
Posthumous in 2014.
And then again in 2019
for her second feature,
The Farewell, which she wrote,
directed, and co-produced.
The Farewell follows struggling
New York City artist,
Billi, played by Awkwafina,
who travels to China
to visit her dying grandmother.
Wang filmed The Farewell
in the neighborhood
where her own grandmother
actually lived.
And she cast her great aunt, Lu
Hung, as herself in the film.
Last year variety named Wang
one of 10 directors to watch
and Awkwafina won a Golden
Globe for her performance.
The Farewell also won the
Independent Spirit award
for best film.
We look forward to hearing
your conversation everyone.
Bird, take it away.
Thank you.
And I want to thank
everyone for joining us,
especially our filmmakers,
our screenwriters.
I feel so honored to be here
having a conversation with you.
I myself am just
logging in essentially
from Gabrielino-Tongva
lands and Tataviam
lands, which Hollywood
is built upon.
I don't think that's a
fact that's very well known
within many communities.
But I'm very honored to
come here to you today.
But I also have to
mention that, I myself
descend from matrilineal and
matriarchal Indigenous nations.
And so I feel very
humbled myself
to be speaking with such
four powerful women,
such as yourselves.
And I think the great voices
that you bring to your work,
and to our screens, and to
audiences around the world.
So I just want to first
of all say, thank you
for what you give
and what you do.
I wanted to just basically
start our conversation
by I guess asking you--
I think, as a point of
view on our conversation.
I wonder if somebody
could kick us off
just by telling us how they
would describe what they've
defined as their
own authentic voice
that they're lending
to their work.
Does somebody want to
kick us off with that?
Lulu, do you want to start?
Sure.
Yeah.
I think it took me
a really long time.
I think I'm still in
the process of discovery
of what that means
to have a voice
and to have a
voice in your work.
So for me-- for a long time it
was finding the juxtaposition
of pathos and humor,
which for me is
very much at the heart of my
family, my culture, the way
that I see the world, the
way that my family has
taught me to see the world.
So humor was a big part of--
like finding the kind
of humor in my work
that I wanted to
show was a big part
of my process of it landing.
Because humor is so specific
to every culture and it
may not be easily translatable.
So that was a really difficult
thing when I set out especially
to make The Farewell, to
say, oh, this is funny.
And if someone goes,
well is it funny?
And how do you break
that down, right?
Because what someone
finds funny it just is.
And so that was
a big exploration
of that particular
type of humor.
And especially with a visual
medium like film for me
it was really a
journey to figure out
how to actually represent
that humor on screen,
so that it translates to
not only to audiences,
but through multiple
different cultures.
That's great.
Thank you.
Ligiah, what about you?
I think for me the
thing that I always
have to keep going
back and forth about,
is how I see myself on the
inside, which is 100% Mexican,
and how I need to see
myself in the entertainment
industry, which is as a Latina.
And for me, a Latina, the word
Latino, or Latinos and now
Latinx, for example,
is not really a word
that we ever use in the
countries that we come from.
We never say we're Latinos.
We always say we're Mexican,
or we're Argentinian,
or we're Colombian,
or we're Brazilian.
But in Hollywood, because
we have so little power,
and because our stories are seen
so rarely, a little bit more
in television now but
almost nonexistent in film,
unless the movie is coming
from another country.
So I'm talking about the ability
for us who live in this country
to be able to tell our stories.
That is almost nonexistent
in this country.
The only way that we
can have some power
is by uniting with the word
Latina, or Latinx, or Latino.
But for me I will
always be a Mexican.
That's how I see myself,
that is my heart.
And so it's navigating
that back and forth
and finding specificity.
So that we don't just see a
Latinx character in television
and film, but then
we actually bring
in the specificity of what
that character may bring,
based on where they came from
or what their heritage is.
All right.
Thank you for that.
Misan, what about you?
I think my--
I mean what I've always wanted
is to really expand what
it means to be Black on screen.
That I found very
early on that we were--
as a Black writer I
was only really allowed
to inhabit quite small
spaces that there
was a lane that I was allowed to
be in, which was about you look
at the kinds of stories that
I would be allowed to tell,
and the kind of stories
that Black people would
be allowed to appear in.
And I was very
often told, when I
was developing Belle for
example, they would say,
oh, this just doesn't
feel like a Black story
because it's not for example
urban enough that it's not.
Or there would be a real focus
on Black pain to the point
that it almost becomes that--
you say, what are you
actually trying to say?
So I think it's to expand the
stories we are allowed to tell
and stories that reflect
the entirety of who we
are as a people and as a race.
And to expand as
well what people
would expect to
see when they look
at a film with a
Black person and not
be defined by the stories that
people who for whatever reason,
those are the stories they feel
comfortable for us to be in.
That we need to in the same
way as in the greater society,
we need to expand
the spaces where
people would expect to see
us and not be uncomfortable.
We need to have that
on screen as well.
And that has been my
quest in defining myself
as a storyteller.
Is to be able to tell my
story and not the story
you expect me to tell.
All right.
Thank you for that.
And you, Máijá.
How would you define your voice?
Well, I think as an
Indigenous filmmaker,
as someone who's Blackfoot
and Sámi it's always about
centering myself in my
community and being responsible
and accountable to my own
community first and foremost
and thinking about my own
people as my audience.
To speak about that idea of
expanding the types of stories
that can be told, I think it's
about thinking about the way
that Indigenous people have
been represented on screen.
Since film first
started rolling it's
been decades and decades
of misrepresentation
and of outsiders
telling our stories.
So for me, it's about always
centering myself within my
within my communities
as an Indigenous person
and centering Indigenous
people as my audience.
And then I work from there.
Well, I think you might be
being a little modest when
you're saying decades
of misrepresentation.
more like a century perhaps.
Yeah. let's use century.
[LAUGHTER]
10 decades.
So let's say that.
But I think all of us coming
from the distinct communities
that we're all coming
from, I think we
all share that in common.
We all have that history
of misrepresentation
of our own peoples,
that I think definitely
affects I think, our
movement, our attempts to move
within a particular
industry and within a world
that I think has
preconceived notions of us.
Misan, I heard you say it
in one of your lectures,
that you said the word
diversity is complicated.
Because in order for
there to be diversity
you have to acknowledge what
the actual point of view is.
How would you describe the
historical point of view
that I guess we're challenging.
I think the point of view
that normality is white, male,
heterosexual, and
that their stories
are inherently interesting.
And there needs to
be no justification.
You just have to be and
your story is interesting.
Whereas to convince
people that I then
have to be diverse from that.
And once you say that,
you're immediately
saying that that is normal
and my stories are not.
And some accommodation has to be
made in order to tell my story.
And you can end up
that telling my story
is like castor oil-- you
know, it's good for you,
you've got to do it.
But actually, it's not pleasant.
It's not the norm.
And I think we need
to get away from that.
The white male that I've
discussed at the beginning--
and nothing against it--
is diverse, to me.
So exactly-- they
are diverse to me.
And the feeling
for those stories
are somehow
inherently interesting
and our stories have to
be justified, that is
what I feel very strongly
against, because to me,
a lot of those stories are
specifically not interesting.
It depends where
you stand before you
find something interesting.
And I'm worried about the
use of the word diversity,
because it entrenches a
particular point of view
that that is where
we are looking from,
and that all the rest
of us are diverse.
I worry about that as a concept.
Although, Misan, I have to say,
I was recently putting together
a writers' room, and
I said, you know,
maybe we should get a
white male in here in order
to have diversity,
because right now, we have
only women and women of color.
And everyone said, we don't
need that point of view.
Everyone knows that point
of view plenty fine.
So we ended up not doing it.
I love that.
Well, I do believe that
one of the things you know
we are commenting on is kind of
who determines the frame, who
determines what's centered,
who determines the norm.
While we don't
acknowledge that enough,
I think also one of the
things that it definitely
leads to is creating bias.
It creates historical
bias against all of us
you know who are not
represented in that norm
or maybe misrepresented
to that norm.
But I just wondered
if anyone had
any ideas about what
are some steps we
can take to overcome that bias?
Because I think we do see it--
it's continually perpetuated.
Well, I would say
one is education.
One thing that I always
say-- and I work much more
in television than
I work in features,
so I hope it's OK to talk
a little bit about that
experience in terms of feature--
but one of the
things that I say--
and I'm in the Equity
and Inclusion Committee
for the Writers
Guild of America,
and we have dealt with a
lot of issues of not just
sexual harassment, but
harassment and racism
in the writers' rooms.
And one thing that
I always say is
writers who get a
show for the most part
are being hired because
they are talented writers.
They are incredible
storytellers.
They are not getting
hired because they
have leadership skills.
But they are put
in positions where
they have to be leaders of
not only the writers' room,
but an entire crew and
a whole group of actors.
And nobody has given them any
kind of information or classes
or leadership seminars of how
do you run a crew of 300 people?
What is acceptable
behavior and not?
What is considered
racist or not?
Who can help you navigate
these worlds and these stories
and these people?
And so now more
than ever, I think
it's super important, because
we no longer just have
four networks with
30 shows being
put on the air every year.
We have dozens of cable
networks and streaming
services in addition
to network television.
We have 500 shows in
production a year.
So we have a whole
generation of writers
that are being put
in these positions
with absolutely no
knowledge of how to lead.
And so a lot of the issues
that I think we see--
also in feature
sets, by the way,
because it's not like directors
are given leadership skills,
either--
but more so I think
in television,
because there's just
so many shows that
are being produced a year.
That I think it's vital
to as part of getting
hired that you are
actually receiving
information and
training on these issues
as well as just some
leadership skills that
can guide you through a process
of running a room and beyond.
I think that's important.
I agree with the
issue of training,
because one of the things--
I think Elle-Máijá has a really
interesting story of when she
was you know co-directing
her first feature.
She did a particular level
of training with her crew
and I think with actors and
with communities and everybody
who was really involved in the
creation and the production
of her feature film.
Can you describe
that a bit much?
Because it was more
like around what
you would call, I guess you
said, cultural competency,
is that correct?
Yeah, so who is behind
the camera absolutely
shapes the narrative.
And within the Indigenous film
community, we have quite a few
really talented writers and
directors and producers,
but we don't have
enough people working
in the technical departments.
We don't have enough people
working as sound recordists,
editors, all of those things.
And who makes up a crew
absolutely influences the story
that you're telling.
And so as an
Indigenous filmmaker,
I thought it was so crucial
that we hire as many Indigenous
people within our
crew, especially
in those key
technical positions.
But what we're recognizing is
that there aren't enough of us
to be working on all the films
that are being made right now.
And so we took a
two-fold approach.
One was that we
recognized that we
had to hire a lot of
non-Indigenous crew members
who were lovely people.
But there's a lot of
work to do in terms
of unlearning
colonialism, unlearning
this complicated narrative
that we're all sitting in,
and finding new ways
of moving forward.
So what we did was we held a
mandatory cultural competency
training, an Indigenous history
training for the entire crew
before we went into
production, which in a way,
was to just sort of ground
everybody in a place of respect
and understanding that we have
a lot of work to do together.
And the second thing
that we did was
that we hired 11 Indigenous
youth, young people wanting
to work in film in all of the
key technical departments,
in order to build capacity,
in order to move forward,
and to understand that
one key way of dismantling
these systems of
oppression and systems
of power that really shape the
kinds of stories that are being
told onscreen is to build
capacity within the Indigenous
film community itself.
Thank you.
I think that's such
an interesting model
to contemplate.
We have to acknowledge, I
think, in this moment in time,
given our pandemic and given
the state-sponsored terrorism
that's happening against
Black people in our country,
it's like we're
starting to recognize
these systems of power
and white supremacy that
exists not only in our political
systems in our country,
but I definitely think that
exist within our industry.
And I think if we're going
to continue to have an impact
and to create change, I
think those systems need
to be questioned more, and that
people need to be trained more.
Lulu, you were just
talking about having
staffed a writers' room.
Can you describe
how we all should
be getting into the room?
How did you get into the room
in order to get to this point
where you are?
I mean, honestly, I've never
written in a room before,
so I was told by a couple
of my writers, they said,
this is unlike any room
I've ever experienced.
And I think in some ways,
because I didn't experience
the hierarchy and sort
of the abuse that is
so common in writers' rooms--
I said, we're a team.
Here's a group of
people who have
very different backgrounds,
very different experiences, who
are all tremendously
talented, so why
wouldn't we just talk
about everything?
I had to actually teach
some of the writers who
have been in a lot
of rooms and rooms
where they're not
allowed to speak up--
one woman kept raising her hand.
I was like, why are
you raising your hand?
Just talk.
And so it is so strange to
kind of realize, here I am,
the showrunner, and I don't
have experience in a room.
So I would often turn to her
and say, having been in rooms,
how is this normally done?
And then in other ways,
it was just organic.
You learn to be friends,
you ask each other
for their perspective.
And it always made
the story better--
always, right?
I think when people
are fearful and they
don't give their perspective,
that's not helping the show.
That's going to hurt
me and the show.
If someone says, you
know, actually, I
have the same background
as this character,
this is not how we
would say things.
I'm like please,
please, please tell me.
Do you want to take a look at
it, do you want to take a pass?
Call your father--
what would he say?
Like, all of those
things are what make
this story rich and authentic.
So I don't know why any
showrunner would ever
want to keep people
from expressing that.
That's just purely ego
and it's stupidity.
I agree.
Misan, you came from a
background of being I believe,
a doctor.
And were you a surgeon as well?
Yeah, I was critical
care-- emergency room.
Critical care before you
became a screenwriter.
I mean, what was that path like?
I mean, ultimately getting
to have your feature films
produced and made and shared?
There obviously
was a journey there
and you had to get into
those decision-making rooms.
How did you do that?
Well, how I came
into screenwriting,
actually, dovetails very
well with this conversation
we're having today.
I went to the cinema
and I watched a film.
And it was a film about slavery.
And there were no
Black people in it.
It was one of
these stories where
we knew slavery was
appalling and terrible,
because the white wife of
the white male character
kept having her had dinner
parties disrupted by his zeal
to end slavery.
And I just didn't
see any Black people.
And suddenly, I felt
that I never saw myself.
If cinema is-- really, it's like
the home movie of the world,
isn't it, really?
It's where we go and we see
ourselves, and we're not there.
And when we are there, we're
horribly misrepresented.
But you don't know.
You sit there sort of balancing
between the thrill of seeing
yourself and the embarrassment
of how you're portrayed,
you know?
And I just got to the
point where I just
wanted to see something
that I would want to see.
I wanted to see myself
and I wrote a screenplay.
It may seem sort of
rather an odd thing to do,
but as a doctor, obviously,
you tell stories all day.
So it isn't as far of a journey.
But it was a desperate
yearning need
to see myself represented
on screen in a way
that I recognized.
And I think that many
of us feel that--
that it's like being
a member of a family--
I said this before--
and you're watching the
home movies of the family
and you're not there.
You're not there.
You've been excluded
and you go, why?
And so that was how I started.
And that was the beginning
of my journey to write.
And I imagine you had to deal
with many gatekeepers, which
is actually meant
to be that you know
the thrust of our
discussion today,
because I think we recognize
that there are decision makers.
There are gatekeepers.
There are the ones who make
the decisions to, I guess,
allow some of us in.
Ligiah, what has
been your experience
in navigating the gatekeeping,
I guess, of the industry?
Well, I also didn't
start as a writer.
I actually started
as an executive.
So I was an executive
in television
and I was also an
executive on features.
I worked within a
studio system and I also
worked within a network system.
And in every case, I
was the only Latina.
And sometimes, I was the only
Latina on the entire floor--
not just even in my department,
but the entire floor.
And so I always felt
I had a responsibility
in those positions to make
sure that the shows that I was
overseeing or the movies
that I may be doing
had representation,
which wasn't the case.
So I understand
it from that side.
And I and I understand
the importance
of having executives
of color and producers
of color in those
positions that might
help us get through
the door, because I
have been that person.
At the same time, I think
that a lot of what could help
is for networks and for studios
to actually have a mandate.
And I know they
hate that word and I
know that they hate
using that, because they
feel like, no, we just
need to allow the filmmaker
to be able to tell the stories
that they want to tell and work
in their creative
environment or whatever,
and I am all for that.
But I think that a lot of
this has to come from the top.
They have to understand
that we are so far
behind where we need to be
in terms of what the studios
and networks are
representing in television
and what the world
actually looks like.
That unless they really start
mandating certain things,
I'm not sure things are
going to change drastically.
But for me, I just feel
like I try to tell the best
stories that I can.
One way that I have been
able to navigate this
is that I never set out to
only be a network writer
or I never set out to be
only a feature writer.
Like, I will only do
features or I will only
work in network
television, which
is not even a thing
anymore, because there's so
many streaming services.
But at the time, it was.
So the way that I have
navigated this bias
is for me not to think of
myself as just like I will only
do primetime television or
I will only do features.
That was never really the way
that I thought about my career.
When I transitioned from
being a studio or network
executive to being a
writer, one of the reasons
why I did that is
because I wanted
to have control over the
stories that I was putting out
into the world, which I really
didn't as a network or studio
executive, right?
So when I made that
transition, I decided,
if somebody wants to tell the
story in preschool animation,
I will do it in
preschool animation.
If somebody wants to
do this as an MOW,
meaning movie of the week, for
Hallmark Hall of Fame, which
is how I did the Alicia
Keys project, Firelight,
I will do it in television
and for Hallmark Hall of Fame.
So allowing myself
the opportunities that
go beyond where you
really usually think
of where your story
should be told.
It's a way that I have been
able to navigate this bias.
That I have gone from
working on an NBC show
to working on Go Diego, Go.
And that was a preschool
show on Nickelodeon.
And everybody said, you
can not take that job.
You cannot do that job, because
you will never make it back
to network television.
And I thought to
myself, how do I
say no to a show that is going
to have a Latino lead, that
is going to teach kids Spanish,
and the importance of science?
Like, I literally could not
see a down side to that.
And then I went from that to
releasing La Misma Luna, which
Fox Searchlight bought.
So a lot of this
for me was like I
can't worry about what people
may think because I'm working
in preschool TV or am I
doing a cable movie instead
of a feature film.
I just want to work
at the places that
are willing to tell my stories.
And so instead of
always thinking about,
oh, this story is never
going to be able to be told--
no, I just go to
the places that are
willing to tell the kinds of
stories that I want to do.
And that has helped
me not go crazy
and not to think about the
negative aspects of what we do.
But like I said
earlier, until the top
and the CEOs at these
companies really
try to create some
sort of mandate
for what needs to
happen, I'm not
sure how much is
going to change.
Thank you for that.
I think you've been a master
at the navigation, obviously.
I wonder, does anybody
else have any comments,
I guess, about gatekeepering,
gatekeeping, and gatekeepers
and how they've had--
Bird, can I say one more thing?
Do you mind if I just
say one more thing?
I think that the
most powerful thing
that I have ever
done in my career
is to have the
courage to speak up.
So a job was never worth
me not speaking up.
And I think a lot
of us, because we
are the only ones in the room,
whether it's a writer's room
or we're only in an
executive position
or we're the only ones that
are getting the one Latino
movie done in the next
three to five years,
that sometimes, we're too
afraid to say something.
And I think that one thing--
and I'm old enough that maybe
that's giving me the courage--
but I was like this when I
was in network television,
and I had to speak up.
We had a show taking
place in Miami
and there were no Latinos,
not even in the background.
And I was like, you
can't do a show in Miami
without any Latinos not
even on the background.
There were positions
that I took and continue
to take that I think are really
important for those of us who
are working and
for those of us who
are able to develop
and create programming,
that our voices
need to be heard.
One thing that I'm
very clear about when
I go in, especially in
children's programming,
where a lot of times, they're
trying to make everybody
just be like everybody
else, I always
say a character can not be
replaceable or interchangeable
if it's a character of color.
Yes.
So I don't want you
to just be able to put
anybody else in that role.
And I know that there is a
way, and some people do that,
but being able to say
that, and then being clear,
if you're going to
develop with me,
this is the person that
you're actually going to get.
And you cannot assign me a
composer because you have been
working with that composer for
the last 10 shows that you did.
You have to ask me if I have
an opinion about a composer
of color that I might
want to use instead
of the white composer that you
have been using for the last 20
years.
Like, being able to empower
yourself as a creator of color
and not allow these
things to continue
because you are afraid
that your shows aren't
going to make it on the air.
Unless we speak up, these
things are going to continue.
So the way that I see
it is even if I am--
let's suppose that
I'm fired, which
hasn't happened that
often, by the way--
but let's suppose
that I am fired--
I can promise you that that
executive or that producer
is not going to forget
that conversation.
And that might bring change
to somebody else in another
project that is not
even related to me,
because they're always going to
remember the outspoken Ligiah,
Mexicana, that came in here and
told us, you cannot do this.
And so I feel strongly that
those of us who are working
must have the courage to
speak up in these situations.
Thank you.
If I might say, I think also, at
this moment, one sort of feels
exhausted by this
process and it's time
to stop asking nicely as though
we were asking for a favor,
and try and change perception
that what we are doing
is just demanding
normal rights, you know?
And not feel all
the time that one
has to somehow persuade people,
but rather, look at the wider
society that will accept that.
Change things so that people
accept that the present status
quo is inherently wrong.
And therefore, it's how are
we going to put it right--
not how are we going to
have the favors dispensed.
Our stories matter.
You know, Black stories, Latina
stories, Indigenous stories--
our stories matter.
Our representation matter.
Our lives matter.
And we need that to be inherent,
not just in our industry,
but in the wider society.
Because people need
to understand that
the present status
quo is unsustainable.
And it is very difficult,
and I agree with you,
because sometimes, it's
very difficult to speak out
when you're a writer.
And from my point
of view, when you're
getting notes, which some
notes can be just horrendous.
And you think, if
I say anything,
is it better if I'm working
at it from the inside and all
of that?
And after some point, we're
just exhausted with it.
And we need to be heard and
our stories need to be heard.
And we can't do it alone without
the wider society accepting
and understanding that
the current status quo is
unsustainable and unacceptable.
Yes.
Lulu, can you share
us a point of view
on navigating with this
world, with gatekeepers
and your talent?
Yeah, I think one
of the things I
tell so many filmmaker friends
of mine who are women of color
is--
we talk a lot about do
you build your own table,
do you try to get a
seat at the table.
We have these debates of we just
gotta say forget the system,
and just build our own table.
But you have to
have the numbers.
You have to have power in
order to go and build a table.
And the generations
that came before us,
they didn't have that choice.
They had to find a
seat at the table
and asked to be let in
order to build their clout,
their, whatever,
reputation, all of it,
in order to go and maybe
create their own table.
And so I think
that for me, I have
to take this perspective of
abundance, which is something
that we all have to
unlearn, of not thinking
of ourselves as
special or singular,
and there's only room for one.
Because as everyone comes up,
that's how we have more power,
create--
those are the people that
you can turn to and say--
because when you're there
alone, it's terrible.
It's like you don't
know if you're crazy
or they're crazy,
because they're
convincing you that you're
the one who's crazy.
But if you have other
people around who
had this other perspective,
it's just better.
And so one of the things I
talk about with these friends
is transparency, where
anybody who asks me,
I'll show them my contracts.
I ask friends of mine to
show me their contracts.
I think it's really
important that we
have comps with
other filmmakers who
have done a first
feature, a second feature,
are doing their first TV show,
going, well, what did you make?
And what rights were you given?
Where you allowed
to pick your DP,
were you allowed to pick
the writers in your room.
So I always tell my friends
not to get overly excited
when they get offered a deal.
Before you get excited,
do your research.
Talk to as many
people as possible
who have worked
with this company.
Find out how they
treat people of color,
how they treat both
financially and creatively.
And that way, they are
sort of armed with facts
to go back to their
reps to say, I'm
not going to take this deal.
I'm not going to
come to the table
and be grateful, which is
what they're expecting.
And so I said, don't
stop getting excited,
stop being grateful,
and make sure
that they're actually val--
valuing?
Sorry, I just had a brain fart.
They're actually giving as
much value as you deserve.
And unfortunately, sometimes,
that means you have to say no.
And that's something
I talk a lot about,
as well-- is the
power of saying no.
Because before I
made The Farewell,
I was just saying
yes to everyone
because I was so desperate to
make a story, to make a film,
and get it out somehow.
But there is such an
emotional deficit.
Like, there's a payment that
goes, and nothing is for free.
And so you might
say yes to somebody,
and they turn your story
into something else.
You're not properly
paid to do this work.
You can burn out so quickly.
And so I think that the
importance of having
the confidence and the value
in your own work to say,
I'm not going to do this work
unless the proper conditions
are met, because I can't do my
best work if these conditions
are not met.
And if I can't do my best
work, when the work comes out,
and people go, well look,
here's an Asian woman,
and we gave it a shot, we
did this film, but it failed,
it's going to be put on you.
And so that's the
first thing I say
to anybody who works with me,
is like, if you value what I do,
these are the terms
in which I need
to do my best work, including
bringing my own collaborators,
who may not have the same
credits, who you may not
be as familiar with.
But this is the
organic process for me.
And if I can't have my
process, then you're
not going to get the result
that you're looking for.
Thank you.
Elle-Máijá, I wanted to give you
a chance to comment before we
may have to move
on to questions.
Sure.
Yeah, I'm loving
listening to everybody.
I really appreciate
what Lulu said
about this notion of abundance.
About thinking differently about
our stories, about stories that
come from BIPOC communities,
about stories that
come from voices that have
been marginalized or silenced
or erased within the film world.
And I really appreciate
what she said
about building a new process
and about considering
who these gatekeepers are.
So when it came to
The Body Remembers
When The World Broke Open, it's
a film about two Indigenous
women in East
Vancouver in Canada,
it covers issues of
domestic violence,
and it's a bit of a heavy film,
and we had a really hard time
closing our financing gap.
And we had a really hard
time finding a distributor,
because people continually
said, this story is important,
we understand it's
an important story,
but we don't know how
we're going to market it.
We don't know how we're
going to sell this story.
And we kept getting that
same sort of response.
And then the film got in front
of Ava DuVernay and Tilane
Jones at ARRAY Releasing.
And they decided to pick up
the film and that changed
everything for us.
And I think what
that speaks to is
the fact that when
there are people
who come from marginalized
communities, who are BIPOC,
in these positions of power,
people who are able to shift
the narrative, and to show that
there is an audience for films
like mine and for the
others on the panel,
it changes everything.
And so now that film
is available on Netflix
to such a broad audience.
And what we're finding is that
despite the fact that it's
such a specific story
about two Indigenous women,
it has so many universal themes.
And there's so many people
who are drawn to the story
on a personal level
who aren't Indigenous,
who aren't from Canada.
And so it really
is about shifting
who is in these
positions of power.
It's about holding gatekeepers
accountable, and acknowledging
that as long as
there are straight,
cisgendered, white men in
positions of power deciding
whose stories get told
then who's don't, we're
going to continue to see
the same issues replicated
and the same voices
being silenced.
So I have so much gratitude
for people like Ava and Tilane
at ARRAY, because they're
just opening so many doors
for voices like mine.
And I think that really
speaks to a brighter
future for all of us.
And I hope that this moment that
we're experiencing right now
in terms of a reckoning with
race relations in the States
and also in Canada--
I hope that the work
that's being done right now
continues into the future.
And I really hope we see
lasting change and lasting
accountability.
You know what--
I also think it's
important for artists who
are not a person of color,
for them to also be
thoughtful about the projects
that they take on.
Are they asking a question
when they are brought in
to do a Latino story, have
you met with Latino writers?
Have you met with
Latino directors?
That they themselves
also look at this journey
as their journey, as well.
And I think that
everybody should
be able to tell the stories
that they want to tell.
So I have a different
opinion about a person
who may be passionate about a
story that they want to tell.
I'm talking about dealing
with these gatekeepers
at the studios.
If you are being brought in to
do a story that is not really
your own, are you asking
questions yourself?
So not just ask asking
those questions.
It's so sad for me to know
that there are two big Latino
movies that are going
to be released this year
and neither one is being
directed by a Latino.
And thank god that one
of them is directed
by a person of color, but we
are still having our stories
told by non-Latinos.
And so we have a
responsibility to speak out,
but I think hopefully the
community as a whole is also
speaking up about these
issues and saying,
who have you met on this?
It's so interesting-- I think
four of the last six Academy
Awards for director have
been given to a Mexican,
but we still can't
find directors
that can direct the movies
that the studios want
to make about us.
It's just the irony of
it is incredible to me.
I love that you're saying--
it's interesting, because I'm
just thinking as a metaphor,
as an analogy, when we travel,
at least when I travel,
or when I go out to LA to go
to a restaurant, I'm like,
let's go to that
Vietnamese restaurant.
It's full of Vietnamese people.
That's a good sign when it's
filled with Vietnamese people
or wherever.
If you're traveling, you want
to go to the local places
and you look to make sure that
not only the people cooking,
but the people eating are
actually from that background.
And it gives it legitimacy.
And how do we not do that with
movies, you know what I mean?
If I want to see
a Mexican film, I
want to make sure that
the people cooking
the meal and the people
who are coming to the meal
are giving it the
validation, because that's
saying to me that that's
an authentic experience.
And I talk a lot with
friends about my experience
when I get notes from people who
don't come from my background.
how do I say it?
How do I say, you
don't get this--
you don't get it, because
you're not from where I'm from.
And it took me a long time
to actually find those words,
because you still
have to be polite.
You can't just come straight
out and be like, hey,
if you don't let me
do it, that's racist.
Like, you can't really say
that, right, to an exec.
So there's this
diplomatic way of saying,
I really respect
your opinion, but I
don't think this is a story no.
I think this is a
cultural no that you
don't understand
because you don't
come from where I come from.
And they really respond
well-- at least producers
that I've worked with
really respond well to that.
But I think you're
right, Ligiah.
I wish that
executives, producers,
people who are working
with creators that
are from different
backgrounds don't
wait until they say to you--
because it's a lot to
carry all of that pressure.
For them to come to
you and say, hey, you
don't come from where I come.
Like, you should recognize that
and say that right up front
and give them the space so
that the creator can point when
something is a cultural
difference and a perspective
difference rather than a
purely technical craft no, you
know what I'm saying?
Yeah, and also,
looking at your film,
I was thinking about when
I watched it, sometimes,
even though it is a cultural
thing that people may not
understand, sometimes,
it is in the specificity
that you find commonality.
So I remember when I
went to see your film,
that a whole cemetery scene
with the crying and the food,
and it was like Día
de los Muertos for us.
Like, it is crazy.
And I don't know if
you guys know this,
but Coco is the highest
grossing Pixar movie in China.
I think it made $200
million in China.
And I was like, I
wonder why Coco made
so much money in China, right?
And it's like Coco can
not be more specific.
It is so specifically Mexican.
But there's a whole group of
people that saw this movie
and found commonality in
the specificity of it.
And sometimes, what executives
are really afraid of
is the thing that they
should fear the least,
because people will find
their way through the movies.
They will have
some understanding.
The same thing happened with
Under the Same Moon in Jordan,
where I was thinking,
how are people going
to relate to this in Jordan?
Well, they were
experiencing a huge amount
of people coming in from Syria.
And all of a sudden, there was
so much commonality in that.
And so I would hope
that also, it's
something that they look at.
I saw your movie, Lulu,
and I immediately connected
with so many of the things,
even though we could not
be more far apart in
terms of our cultures
or our backgrounds.
Thank you.
I loved your movie, as well.
I think one of the
things that exercises
me is, how do we stop
this being our problem,
we have to overcome.
Because actually, the reality
is, it is not our problem.
It's the problem with
the people around us.
And how do we make sure that
even the perspective from which
we look at what to be
done, what has to be done
isn't just focused on us having
to be super women or do this
and how do we overcome, but how
do we change the conversation
to, what are you doing?
I mean, you are
wrong, therefore,
how are we going to
involve you in the solution
and not have it about us
having to overcome you?
How do you make you
part of the solution?
And I think when we talk
about gatekeepers, obviously,
having more diverse--
I've used the word--
gatekeepers is going
to make a difference.
But there is also the
majority population
that they have to
be part of this.
And we can do things
like mandating things,
as we discussed earlier.
But there's also somehow,
that hearts and minds
have to be changed, right?
That's what sort of exercises
me, because people also
have to be willing.
Otherwise, what happens
is that they'll make that.
I remember being told,
a filmmaker here,
oh, we already
made a Black film.
They made one three years
before, and so that's that.
As opposed to thinking,
this is just normal.
This is normal life
and this is just how
the world when I step foot
outside my door looks like.
And this is what it
should look like here.
And I can understand that your
stories are interesting to you,
my stories are
interesting to me.
Let's make them all.
That's what exercises me--
is how do we stop approaching
this is our problem,
and also focus on
how we can make
it a wider society
or wider problem
within the industry,
and not something
that we have to overcome.
But that there should
not be that resistance
in the first place.
Maybe in Utopia, but
that's what I think
we should be driving towards.
It's exhausting-- can I
just say, when you go in
and pitch a story, and
the first half hour,
you're not pitching your story,
you're not pitching yourself.
You're pitching your relevance.
And I had a most wonderful
sort of experience
of pitching to an
African-American woman
executive, and it was
like suddenly-- it
was like having the weights
on your feet, the anvil that's
being held on your feet gone,
because I could suddenly just
pitch.
Pitch my story,
pitch what it was
without this sort of preamble.
And it's to how do we get
there where there isn't
that resistance in
the first place,
rather than us having to
always be so special in order
to be able to get through.
In Canada, we're kind of
in this unique position,
and we've modeled what's
happened in Australia and New
Zealand in terms of
Indigenous stories, Indigenous
representation.
Indigenous people are
leading the conversation
and we're seeing
that now in Canada.
We have the Indigenous Screen
Office, and a lot of work
has been placed into developing
something called the Pathways
and Protocols Document.
And it's literally a guide
for non-Indigenous people
wanting to work with
Indigenous communities,
wanting to tell stories
with Indigenous content.
And in a lot of ways,
it's a way of holding
non-Indigenous
people accountable,
because it's trendy right now
to tell Indigenous stories.
Like, every week, I get
multiple emails, multiple calls
requesting that I
direct or help write
the story that has an Indigenous
character or Indigenous
whatever.
And it's such an
incredible resource
to have this Pathways and
Protocols Document to say,
here, look at this
document, read it.
This is what you need to do.
And these are the questions
you need to ask yourself.
Should you be
telling this story?
Are you the right person
to tell this story?
Have you connected with
community communities
in a responsible,
ethical, meaningful way?
And if they haven't, they
have that document to look to.
And so I think we
need to continue
to move in that
direction when it comes
to telling all stories
that are relevant
or represent BIPOC communities
or LGBTQ2S communities,
or the disabled community.
I think there needs to be
some sort of this mandated
documents in a way that
serve us as a tool,
because there's so much
emotional labor, so much
education that we have
to do as the other
when it comes to
helping our own stories.
And having that document,
having that tool
has been such a such a
weight off my shoulders
as an Indigenous storyteller.
And I think it also protects
our communities, because there's
kind of this toxic form
of extractive filmmaking
that has existed since the
cameras first started rolling.
So people of color,
Indigenous people,
anybody who is the other has
been fetishized or romanticized
or misrepresented in
front of the camera.
And there's just so much work
to do to unlearn all of that,
to change all of those
ways of operating.
And when it comes to, like
I said, this extractive form
of filmmaking, it
comes from people
who are not from those
communities going in
with a voyeuristic lens,
and getting it all wrong
every single time.
They always get it wrong.
And so it needs to
shift to us being
the ones telling the stories,
to us leading the conversation.
And like I said, this Pathways
and Protocols Document
has been such a lifesaver
for me and I think a lot
of other Indigenous creatives.
I believe that we
have to wrap up--
I mean, in order to ask
a couple of questions.
And so I'm going to
hand it off to Shawn
to provide us with
our questions.
Lulu, Bird, Ligiah,
Misan, Elle-Máijá,
what a beautiful conversation.
And thank you for
being so transparent.
The Academy Dialogues
was created as a platform
to give our members
an opportunity
to have truthful and
transparent conversations,
and I wanted to ask
you what dialogue
do you hope this conversation
will inspire in others.
We can start with you, Bird.
Oh, with myself?
Well, I think so
many things that I
feel like our panelists spoke
about today was really, about,
one, the distinctness that their
voices is lending to the form--
the form of storytelling,
the forms of storytelling,
forms of cinema.
But also, that
there are audiences
who are hungry for it.
That there's a disconnect
between the stories
they're trying to tell and
what the audience wants.
And I think that
that is our industry,
and I think that
our industry could
be a lot more bountiful and
successful if these voices were
really supported
and really brought
to the screens for
these hungry audiences
to experience and to share.
Thank you.
Lulu, what dialogue do you
hope this conversation will
inspire in others?
I think that around what we were
saying of putting the pressure,
putting the responsibility
on the gatekeepers
themselves, the executives,
so know the writers,
the directors are
not always the ones
having the conversation
ourselves to say, how do we
know better this situation.
That hopefully, the
members will talk more
and look at their own
position in the industry
and their own power
and say, you know
what are the questions
that I can do better.
Also, how do I
better educate myself
so I can participate and
be part of the solution?
And Elle-Máijá,
what about yourself?
Oh, wow, this has been
such a rich conversation.
And I think ultimately,
I hope viewers
and Academy members especially
walk away and take time
to consider how
we're all implicated
in this narrative, how we move
together, how we move forward
together.
And how can we dismantle these
toxic systems of working.
And how can we build
a new way forward.
How can we build models that
are rooted in equity and respect
and accountability.
And how can we build models
of working that are generative
and consider a future
that doesn't necessarily
reflect our present moment,
where we're having to have
this kind of conversation.
I really hope that
in 10 years from now,
we're not having to have the
exact same conversations.
Misan and Ligiah, you both
represent flexibility.
Everyone does, but you
specifically, because Misan,
you came from being
a doctor before.
Ligiah, you spoke about
being an executive.
For a new filmmakers
that are coming up,
how important is it to
be flexible with going
after your dreams
and your passions?
I think from my point of view,
it's less about being flexible
than about having
know confidence.
What I often find--
I sometimes mentor
beginning writers of color,
and they say to themselves so
much, am I ready, can I do it?
And we all know that
there are people
from the sort of
the whiter community
who've walked past a
film set and they're
ready to direct a
Marvel movie, you know?
Whereas as a woman and
as a woman of color,
you'll say, oh, am I ready?
So it's less about
being flexible
than about saying, yes--
you know, just having a go.
And from the other side, it's
about not having everything
on the shoulders of
one Black filmmaker
so that if that Black filmmaker
has a go and it isn't perfect,
there isn't any bigger
conversation about,
oh, well, we've done our Black
film and it was a disaster,
we're not going to do it again.
Or making each person
representative of everything as
opposed to just them just
trying to make their film.
So I think that's what I hope
will people will take away
from this-- that we have
sort of rich stories to tell,
that we're an asset.
We're not a problem to be
solved, we're an asset.
And that we should
be allowed to try
and allowed to participate
without the huge amount
of pressure that
can be on somebody.
And while we should
be flexible, we
should also ourselves
just not all the time
or be worried about
the consequences.
And those consequences
should not
be disproportionate
to making a film.
It works, it works,
it doesn't work.
It doesn't have to be everything
so that the pressure becomes
too difficult.
Thank you so much.
And Ligiah, did you
want to add to that?
Sure, so I heard a
quote once that said
a nation is only as great
as its dreams and dreams are
dreamt by artists.
Now I have no idea who
originally said that.
I heard that from Tom
Cruise on The Actors Studio,
and it has stuck with
me since that interview.
So what I would say to that
new generation of filmmakers,
writers, artists, is
especially in the world
that we're living in, your
voices and your stories
are vital to our survival.
Yeah, to our survival.
The second thing I
would say, though,
is I heard a statistic that
less than 50% of Americans
actually have a passport,
which I think is a disgrace.
And even a much, much, much
lesser percentage of them
speak a second language.
So when you think about the most
powerful country in the world
delivering the most powerful
content to the world
and less than 50% of us
have actually traveled,
our stories become
so much more vital.
Because it is sometimes
the only window
that the audience
in this country
has about the outside world.
And if you want to know why
this country is where it is,
it's because people
don't leave this country.
They're not experiencing what
is happening in the world.
So just imagine how important
our stories and our point
of view is in trying to
change the perception of who
we are in the world
and who the world is.
And that's why I think it's so
important that our stories are
told and heard and considered.
Wow, Ligiah, thank you so much
for that beautiful answer.
Bird, Lulu, Misan,
and Elle-Máijá,
thank you so much for your
time and for participating
in the Academy Dialogues.
And on behalf of the entire
Academy, thank you so much.
Thank you for having us.
Thank you, very much.